All right.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Patrick Woo and I am going to be
talking about single page applications at
scale.
Going to turn up at Flux capacitor and with
1.21 gigawatts we can get started.
I am a software manager at AWS and we are
building super private stuff for a project
called Beehive.
I love basketball and movies from the '80s.
We have a sponsor also here.
What do I mean by spa at scale?
Single page applications at scale?
Our project is about 200,000 lines of code.
This is pre-transpiled versions of our actual
application with over 50 front end engineers
working on the project across Seattle, San
Francisco, Cupertino and Vancouver.
We have a distributed team.
We are all excited about our launch.
We had a few bumps along the way.
Let's go back in time and I want to talk to
you about our top 5 lessons learned.
First lesson is getting to know our customers.
As engineers, a lot of time we are working
and we are like this works, it works on my
machine, it works on Chrome, I am good, right?
Actually, our customers are also on Edge,
Firefox, Safari and maybe some are on Beaker
I found out.
Cross-browser compatibility is an actual thing.
You might say Patrick, these are Evergreen
browsers and all compliant.
We were trying to get performance measures
working and on Firefox observe without observing
was throwing an error addressed in version
63 but 60 is long-term support.
You say they solved it in version 63 so that
should do the job but actually, on some corporate
environments, not everyone has the latest
version of that particular browser.
We have to think about those users as well.
The other thing is operating system issues.
We use frameworks
like React, Vue, Angular, Babel.
Don't thinks things will just work.
We didn't know scrollbars display on PC.
That one pixel deviation was causing performance
issues and the virtual list kept moving up
and down.
All the people on the business side who had
PCs were complaining so we had to consider
operating systems.
The other thing is testing for great experiences
includes slow connections.
What is awesome with the Chrome dev tools
and I don't know if you are familiar but this
was revealing for us.
People are on slower connections that are
not Wi-Fi and high-speed.
The other thing is thinking about the machines.
We have high powered MacBook pros and that
is awesome but we had to test the CPUs.
There are great tools and some of these are
Open Source projects and one is called web
page test.
We simulate a cable or 3G connection with
this.
Another cool tool we learned was Lighthouse
which was allowing us to see simulated experiences
as well.
It has a really great accessibility score
which is awesome as well.
The second lesson was about documenting our
code.
We got new engineers, 50 engineers, and we
keep growing, and we had to keep shoulder
tapping people like what does this component
do?
Documentation is absolutely pivotal to the
project but it is really hard.
It is hard to main tape, hard to understand
-- maintain -- and difficult to scale.
You would change a particular function and
you wouldn't go back to the documentation
to update it.
That happened way too frequently.
We thought how can we solve this problem?
One thing we introduced was and I know people
might not like this but we actually, you know,
ended up using TypeScript and TypeScript helped
us having documentation in code.
It allows for self-documenting code by providing
great ID support like the auto complete for
props were amazing.
Type checking.
Misspelling a component name helped surface
those.
Require props provided a nice error message.
Helps us re-factor by naming places.
It will help us rename components for the
ones we are working on.
The other thing is TypeScript interface allows
us to be explicit about component props.
We have distributed teams and when we talk
about the components we will builds, we talk
about it through our interfaces we first build
and that was a helpful thing for us to document.
This all goes back to, you know, that awesome
book we might have read, clean code, but the
author of this quote is Gary Booch, not uncle
bob, clean code is simple and direct and clean
code should read like well-written prose and
that is what we are hoping to adopt.
That is great for engineers but doesn't work
for the business stakeholders and designers
we interact with.
The thing we adopted was Storybook.
Storybook for React components rocks.
It allows us to host documentation about our
components, provides a single source of truth
for designers, product owners and our engineers.
One of the problems and why this was pivotal
for us was we would get a spec, continuously
iterating, and I would talk to the designer
and say what is the file?
Is this the actual file?
They are like, yeah, that is the final file.
Are you sure?
Let me reach out to Sandra and she is like
no, this is the ultimate file.
I don't why they don't have code versioning,
maybe they do, but no git for designers and
hard to find the source of truth.
What we ended up doing is Storybook allowed
for a great workflow with design systems and
single source of truth.
We incorporated Airbnb's React sketch app.
Engineer would build a React component, generate
a sketch simple symbol and design team works
on that, and they hand it to us and we employ
it.
It is version controlled by git as well.
Lesson three is tests.
I know this might be obvious but it actually
is one of the most, like, foundational pieces
for us.
Testing might seem obvious, easy, but I emphasize
this as a lesson learned because it helped
us gain confidence in our code.
A lot of times we deployed to prod and we
would not have too much confidence.
We thought it worked on the machines like
the cross-browser compatibility issues and
we reduced a lot of regressions and also reduced
the time to first commit for new hires.
We would get new hires and the code was fairly
well tested it was easy for them to onboard
and within the first one or two days they
were able to commit.
We have a foundational basis and reduces having
to ping additional engineers to figure out
what is going on.
The testing framework we ended up using is
Jest.
It allows us to write tests with enzyme, integration
tests, and allows us to have component snapshot
tests and get visibility into rather than
particular component has changed.
This is from testJavaScript.com which is an
amazing resource.
It goes over the different pieces.
With static tests, you know, to catch typos
and errors, we would use TypeScript for that.
Unit we use Jest and integration Jest end
and end to end, we are experimenting with
using Jest with puppeteer but puppeteer is
only supported on Chrome so that is an issue
we are looking into.
Again, I just really want to highlight how
awesome testingJavascript.com is.
Definitely worth checking out but things still
break in production.
We have the pipeline test.
You know, from this particular environment
to this particular environment, to prod, it
went through code coverage.
I got 80%, I am good.
Integration tests are passing.
And my end to end tests are passing so I should
be good.
I don't have to worry about prod and actually
as an engineering manager, this is my interview
question.
Protip here.
Things can break in production and we need
to think about customers while in production.
We have monitors and alarms to provide visibility
into our production health for applications
to ensure the deployments and dependencies
are there.
Your CDN might go down and don't you want
visibility into what happened?
We are focused on the customer and don't want
them being the manual QA team.
That is why we are focused on monitoring.
We use specifically Cloud Watch and in our
case AWS.
It helps us collect, monitor, act and analyze
on our actual metrics because as Kyle Stenson
of functional light JavaScript mentions, code
you can't trust is code you don't understand.
I would say code you don't test, or haven't
tested, is really code you don't understand
as well.
That is one of the things we learned.
All right.
Lesson four.
YAGNI.
It is a popular term meaning you ain't going
to need it.
As engineers, we find of have a tendency to
fall into tunnel vision.
We tend to get stuck in tunnel vision over
optimizing.
I am trying to reduce time to interact.
I am trying to get the first meaningful paint
time down.
I am trying to reduce the memory heap.
This is ridiculous.
We need to reduce this, Patrick.
We just kind of rat hole into this particular
perspective.
Instead of seeking feedback early and often
in atomic pieces.
When you have an atomic commit and send out
a review and it is an atomic bite size piece
and you want feedback often so you don't create
a massive 20-page code review or pull request
so it helps provide context.
In terms of deployments, we want to think
about the features we are building.
I believe performance is important but first
you need metrics on that and two you want
it in tiny atomic pieces so you can get feedback
early from the customers.
Your customer and business are eager to help
avoid wasting dev cycles.
All we need to do is stop and listen because
who knows.
You might have already built something really
cool, right?
One note about this slide is I also wondered
is this kid really happy he broke the scooter?
He looks kind of happy about getting a skateboard
but, again, anyway.
All right.
The biggest lesson and, you know, I think
if you takeaway anything of the four lessons
we learned, that what I really want to share
with this group is this one.
This biggest takeaway lesson and that is to
be kind, rewind.
Earlier in the day, there used to be a place
we would go and you would just go through
the aisles and pick out a nice movie and then
you go to the checkout and grab a sour patch
kid, a pop, and go home and enter this block
thing into this other device and hit play
and boom!
You are able to watch an amazing movie.
It was awesome.
At the end of it, always on this particular
thing you would see be kind, rewind and because
you want to be thoughtful about the next person
who is going to enjoy this movie you would
be kind and rewind -- most of the time up
less you are super lazy.
The reason I harp on this is because a lot
of us as engineers, at least in my case, I
have met amazing engineer managers, technical
leads and software engineers who showed empathy
and worked with me.
They showed empathy when they reviewed my
code, when I was trying to learn something
complex like maybe even WebAssembly, and they
showed empathy and compassion.
I think a lot of times as these things are
evolving we might lose out on that.
One thing I like to remind our engineering
teams is to continue to show that empathy.
We work with a diverse group of 50 engineers
and one thing we like to do is make sure we
are not too emotional about our code review
process.
You get a 20PCR and might want to be empathetic
but when it comes to pair programming and
helping engineers understand a particular
function also.
That is the biggest lesson I hope everyone
takes away from what I am presenting on.
That is actually it.
That
is my presentation.
Thank you, everyone.
We are out of time.